all right take it off take it off Harry
that's enough
we're already 20% over your suggested
safety limits gotta give it a little
more time no that's it I'm shutting no
no we're almost there we're almost there
you're not breaking Bagla cutest
all right I'm disengaging hey everybody
this is gonna be my flash episode 16
video whole bunch of Easter eggs for og
flash from season one and season two
because iris had to do a bunch of things
that Barry did when he first became the
flash but we also had a couple big
crossovers you probably recognized this
guy from either West world or The Fast &
Furious franchise or this actor from
Glee always a bunch of Glee actors
popping up in the flash every once in a
while so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the DC videos there's a flash ring
giveaway that's going on right now all
you have to do to enter is just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so let's do top 10 WTF comic book
Easter eggs starting with number 10 the
new thinking cap they call it a thinking
cap but it takes Cisco to get it there
but basically they're just replicating
what Devo did in Harrison wells has this
really crazy moment where he seems like
he might turn into a version of devote
himself which basically would make him
the eobard thawne version of wells again
like the picture he's looking at there's
that voice over in the background just
like eobard thawne so the picture he's
looking at isn't his picture it's a
picture of Eva Barth on as wells so
there were just a lot of moments in this
episode that referenced season 1 moments
which they've kind of been doing during
season 4 like even Davos origin story
episode was a flashback to the first
episode covering Duvall
I'm a big fan
so made a lot of sense that the iris
callbacks were to season one moments too
but you know funny observation they
actually do ponder turning the rest of
the three bus metas into chickens in
Harrison wells doesn't throw the idea
out he's like oh yeah we could actually
do that Mad Science is really more of an
area of study
so just stray observations one of my
favorite things about that character is
that he's dead serious when he's talking
about stuff like that
but number nine this might give us an
idea for why coffee shop girl in last
week's episode looked like she wasn't
really happy with Caitlin and Harrison
wells like as they were walking away she
was pondering them as if something bad
were about to happen there were a lot of
people that thought maybe she's sinister
but I still liked the idea that she's
related to Barry and iris like it's the
greatest thing in her life that she gets
to witness the wedding of Barry and iris
so I don't think that she's a threat to
team flash I just think because of all
the stuff that Cisco was talking about
in this like him potentially becoming
just like devote a mad scientist and
going crazy might come to pass in a
version of the future the coffee shop
girl is from so that's why she doesn't
like Harrison wells because she knows
what he might turn into and it's pretty
fair to say that in most timelines
killer frost will go evil at some point
like it's only a matter of time so right
now that's the most likely reason for
her to not like Harrison wells and
Caitlin but really like Cisco elongated
man Barry and iris because thus far it
seems like she's really enjoyed all the
other members of team flash that she's
run into so number eight just keep that
in the back of your mind Harrison wells
potentially going crazy or using the
thinking cap potentially leading to
something really bad because there has
been no technology that they've
introduced on the show that is not later
gone off the rails or been co-opted by
the villain like a really good analogy
to make would be the velocity 7 like
this miraculous thing that gives the
hero a boost but then is later turned
into something really really bad when it
becomes velocity 9 so the thinking cap
is sort of like Harrison wells version
of velocity 9 no way that doesn't go off
the rails later this season but number 7
bit of a comic book Easter Egg Erik fry
the meta who gets his fire Bay's powers
transferred to the new meta that they
then call pyro is a bit of a wink at the
police chief from the new 52 comics
whose name
was fry now he wasn't a meta he was just
a normal police chief but there is no
Eric fry in the comic books and even
though there was a pyro in the comic
books he wasn't a really big character
he was just briefly in the power go
comics and they just kind of went away
like just really minor bit of a legal
issue between Marvel and DC but number 6
bit of a WTF the only thing that upset
me a little bit during the episode was
the way they wrote the Ralphs character
so he was just like the biggest dick to
Iris I understand why they had him do
that because they needed him to be a bit
of a call to action to iris so she kind
of checked herself because she said a
lot of the reason why she felt insecure
was because of herself it had nothing to
do with Ralph
but in pursuit of that they really had
him go over the top and I don't feel
like he would have been that normally
like he's freaked out about the thinker
so it just feels a little jarring when
characters 180 like that so I felt like
that was mostly in the writing like the
actors just have to do whatever the
writers tell them to do number 5 though
iris answers a whole bunch of questions
that people have been asking about her
all season long like you know what's the
deal with her being a reporter did she
quit her job as she's still a reporter
so the way she explains it is that she
was fearless in season 1 season 2 like
literally during season 2 she shoots out
the window in a high-rise then jumps out
without a parachute just totally trust
falling that Barry is going to catch her
when he runs up the building it was this
really cool moment I think it was
episode 10 from season 2
[Music]
and then you get to like season three in
season four and she's a completely
different character so it's like why was
she so fearless then and not now the way
the writers are explaining it via irises
character is blame savat are so if
you're wondering why she's been behind a
desk why she's been doing all the things
that she's been doing this season it's
because she was so traumatized by this
avatar event and she did make a joke
about it a while ago when they saw the
Lego set like when they got shrunk down
so I felt like that was them sort of
teeing up the idea that she might have
some trauma that she hadn't dealt with
yet but they have weird ways of
addressing that on the TV show like
Kaitlyn is a good example like she went
through all this crap in the first two
seasons and they didn't really address
it so I just assumed when she went super
crazy as killer frost during season
three it was just all that stuff inside
her bubbling to the surface that she
hadn't dealt with yet but number four do
they have some of those funny moments
after the swap powers like basically
iris goes through a condensed version of
the arc that Barry went through when he
first got powers so like there's the
funny moment where she's running on the
treadmill and bails out is okay I'm good
I just gradually ran up your speed down
we know Barry did the same thing she
needs to borrow some clothes from
Caitlin I believe this is the second
time the Caitlyn has been naked in front
of team flash the first time being when
Barry changed her after a drunken
karaoke back during season one so again
all kinds of season one callbacks number
three she tries her first big save
saving people from a burning building
that was the first big save that Barry
tried to make back during season one
episode two like his first conscious
save in the middle of the day Oh burning
building got to save everybody they use
it as an opportunity to show you that
she just hasn't quite figured out all
the powers of the flash every speedster
is a little bit different so like Jesse
quick Jay Garrick Wally West they would
come up with their own ways of using
their speed to solve certain problems so
like Barry doing the windmills like a
lot of the basic abilities they all use
but each has their own way of figuring
things out so like Jesse quick might
have an ability that you might not see
Wally West to in the same thing with Jay
Garrick
he's been the flash of Earth 3 for like
30 plus years so he's probably learned a
couple tricks that Barry has not tried
yet but number two big final fight with
pyro bit of a twist on Barry's first
couple of big things that he did with
his powers so remember in the pilot
episode when he ran around the tornado
that's what he tells iris to do except
because it's a fire
she needs to create a tidal wave which
Barry did when he traveled back in time
after the weather wizard episode also
the same episode that eobard thawne
killed Cisco in so thankfully iris did
not accidentally time-travel back into
the past when she was creating the tidal
wave like Barry did but of course at the
end of the episode they're gonna give
Barry his powers back I thought it was
weird that they even put it to a vote
like do you really wanna take these
powers back do you want to give them
back iris like of course they're gonna
give the flash back his power like it
was almost laughable to look on Barry's
face of relief after he got his powers
back like oh thank god that was agony
not having my speed even the actor Grant
Gustin posted this meme to his Instagram
account number one though was that post
credit scene where he's like I never
want to lose you and it's meant to be
this tender moment between the two of
them but
you remember the thinker arc we are the
flash the thinker is eventually going to
need someone else's body so like ralph
says earlier in the episode I'm the only
one with a body that the thinker is
trying to snatch but you know wait for
it not for long because the flash has
all the abilities that the thinker will
need to survive when he absorbs all 12
of the metas powers thinking three steps
ahead how are they going to twist that
nice moment on its head in a couple
episodes so remember this is episode 16
there are 23 total we still have a ways
to go Kevin Smith was even talking about
his episode so there's gonna be some
crazy stuff happening in the next couple
of weeks so when I post my flash trailer
video tomorrow morning I'll just update
the schedule because there might be a
break between episodes next week and I
almost forgot
iris West costume obviously a version of
excesses from the comics I've talked
about that in a couple different flash
videos if coffee shop girl really does
turn out to be one of their descendants
in a speedster it's totally possible she
could be wearing a version of irises
costume so I did a video a little while
ago about Titans doing Jason Todd along
with coffee shop girl stuff that the
flash producers were explaining so you
can watch that if you haven't seen it
already I explained what the producers
said about coffee shop girl and all the
theories that everyone had they said
that people are really close but they're
not 100% on it so just remember that as
well as Harrison wells and what that
thinking cap might end up doing to him
long term so seems really good right now
but usually velocity-9 style that goes
sideways later in the season what I'll
do is only in the giveaway winner when I
post that trailer video tomorrow so
click here for that jason todd titans
flash video and click here for this
really cool documentary on Superman in
the Krypton TV show thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight